[Musique]
bonjour à tous la grande interview avec
cette semaine christian saint-etienne
professeur d'économie professeur au cnam
merci d'être là
merci pour nous aider à décrypter à
comprendre un peu la situation
économique qui est parfois un peu
confuses notamment en france notamment
en europe mais également au niveau
mondial alors il ya bien sûr y'a la
chine il ya une visibilité relative sur
sur l'europe on va regarder tout ça en
détail on commence par la chine parce
que vous avez fait un livre sur le
président chinois xi jinping en
comparaison d'ailleurs avec donald trump
c'est un livre qui est qui ressort en ce
début mars pour nous donner ce que vous
pensez de sa réaction et de ce qui peut
se passer
au lendemain de cette épidémie due
coronavirus parce qu'on voit à peu près
les conséquences économiques
on va être un peu fixé mais les
conséquences politiques en interne ne
sont pas neutres
alors d'abord sur la l'épidémie de la
chine c'est une vingtaine de régions qui
fonctionnent comme des pays européens en
fait et l'état central coordonne les
régions et la complexité de la direction
des régions actuellement en chine c'est
que les responsables du parti communiste
de chaque région sont en fait noté sur
leurs résultats dans la dans la région
sur la base des données qui les envoient
eux-mêmes à à pékin vous vivez à dire
président il a durci énormément
l'organisation est donc
c'est comme des élèves qui
souhaiteraient eux mêmes pour les
examens donc dans le cas de l'épidémie à
one
les responsables locaux n'ont pas voulu
on essayait d'étouffer la faire pour de
l'épidémie au mois de décembre puisqu'à
mi décembre ont commencé à avoir
suffisamment d'informations pour agir
ils ont caché le la nature de l'épidémie
et quand le pouvoir central a pris
conscience deux semaines après de ce qui
se passait et des répercussions sur
l'ensemble de la chine à ce moment-là xi
jinping qui avait déjà terriblement dur
si le rayer le fonctionnement du régime
depuis son arrivée en 2013 à donner un
nouveau tour de vis extrêmement fort et
donc la question politique que vous
posez est là devant nous pour deux à
trois années c'est à dire que la
question c'est comment vont se rétablir
de nouveaux équilibres à l'intérieur du
parti communiste et les relations entre
les régions et le pouvoir central mais
christian saint-etienne la première
partie que vous nous écrivez c'est un
peu ce qui s'était passé avec le strass
oui il y avait eu on avait mis un
couvercle sur la marmite pour éviter que
ça se sache
là ils ont pris quinze jours de retard
mais après on a appris qu'un jour de
retard le président actuel il a quand
même fait la transparence alors non mais
justement ça oui c'est donc c'est un
grand changement par rapport à son
organisation qui était quand même très
très fermé de la part de xia il ya une
volonté de gérer le pays comme à
on disait au xviiie siècle qu'un
dictateur éclairé donc c'est à dire
quelqu'un qui veut bien faire et ce
qu'il va y avoir un changement dans
l'attitude de la gouvernance chinoise
par rapport au reste du monde par
exemple parce que ça prouve quand même
qu'ils se sont totalement inscrit dans
la mondialisation il considère que
phénomène est mondial
donc il faut jouer le jeu vous n'avez
pas l'air convaincu
non c'est à dire qu'ils ont bien
conscience que ils sont inscrits dans la
mondialisation puisque c'est ce qui a
été le levier de développement de la
chine
c'est l'insertion pour l'économie
mondiale qui à perdre s'ils veulent le
garder collet il faut qu'ils jouent les
fous qui n'en respecte dire vous avez
raison ils ont conscience qu'ils doivent
respecter les règles a s'ils veulent
rester inclus dans le système
international
mais malgré tout il ya une question
politique interne parce que la façon
dont xi a pris le pouvoir à partir de
2013 en réalité ils arrivent au pouvoir
à l'automne 2012 au moment où il est
nommé secrétaire général il est élu
président en mars 2013
à partir de ce moment là il faut avoir
une vision de la chine sur deux mille
ans et notamment depuis l'arrivée du
parti communiste en 49
c'est à dire que le pouvoir en chine
traditionnellement c'est un équilibre
entre régions entre le nord et le sud
il ya autant de différence entre le nord
de la chine et le sud de la chine contre
la scandinavie et l'italie du sud
donc c'est un pays extrêmement complexe
et donc le gouvernement de la chine
c'est un gouvernement d' équilibre il ya
deux grands équilibres à respecter entre
le nord et le sud entre l'est et l'ouest
sont les équilibres géographiques
et puis il ya les équilibres politiques
qui sont toujours là qui se jouent
toujours là entre les communistes qui
veulent quand même être proche de la
doctrine communiste et dix ans les
partisans de dengue qui disent voilà il
faut qu'on se développe et en face à
face des compromis donc dans le cadre de
cet ensemble déquilibre ci est arrivé
comme un peu dans un jeu de quilles
repris les choses en main il a pris
l'ensemble du pouvoir que vous décrivez
donc il a écrasé les clans
en prenant le prétexte de la lutte
contre la corruption et il a commencé à
reprendre le pouvoir et ce qui se passe
maintenant c'est que les autres clans se
taisent mais ils sont toujours là
il ya toujours attendre leur heure voilà
donc qu'ils attendent leur heure est
donc là pour la une des raison de
l'accentuation et du durcissement
d'occident cette affaire sexy perd le
contrôle de l'épidémie en interne les
autres clans vont lui dire tu as pris
tout le pouvoir pour qu'elle ait fait
donc donc dans la responsabilité à la
don qu'il tranche ou et une de la raison
centrale pour laquelle il agit aussi
directement et fermement
c'est d'abord pour garder le pouvoir à
l'intérieur de la chine s'est également
aussi pour montrer qu'ils jouent les
règles du dans le cadre des règles
internationales
mais c'est d'abord et avant tout pour
garder le pouvoir à l'intérieur de la
chine
ceci étant il est en état de guerre il
est en état de guerre économique avec
les états unis
alors ça ça ça complique la chose c'est
à dire cet épisode du couronne à virus
arrive dans un contexte moment d'un
double conflit mondial
le conflit à l'intérieur de la troisième
révolution industrielle de
l'informatique et du numérique où les
chinois et les américains trust toutes
les premières places dans cette guerre
le troisième grand acteur économique
mondiale et dans quasiment absent de
puisque il ya des gars femme est décédée
l'équivalent des gars femmes qui sont
les béats thx mais il y a aucun le
leader européen dans la nouvelle
révolution industrielle
donc ce conflit se joue de manière
extrêmement brutale avec les américains
comprend toujours pour des gentils mais
qui sont extrêmement méchant quand il
s'agit de garder le pouvoir
reprennent du pouvoir en l'occurrence
acheter un avantage en l'occurrence ray
rester la première puissance mondiale et
donc ce qui explique ce qui se passe sur
huawei la lutte sur bois way
les américains utilisent le fait qu' ils
contrôlent le système monétaire et
juridique mondial alors comme le dit
économistes il utilise trop les ficelles
actuellement parce que de plus en plus
le reste du monde cherche une
alternative au système monétaire et
juridiques dirigée par les américains
mais donc il ya ce conflit dans le cadre
économique et puis il ya un conflit pour
la place de premier mondial
alors les américains sont la première
puissance mondiale depuis incontesté
depuis une trentaine d'années les
chinois et là aussi sexy et là aussi les
autres clans en interne le surveille
parce que sexy qui a dit je souhaite que
la chine il alors tout le monde savait
que la chine voulait revenir au premier
plan
mais c'est lui qui a dit nous voulons
être la première puisse accepter d'avoir
digital oui notamment mais met donc
c'est lui qui a dit je souhaite que nous
devenions la première puissance mondiale
avant 2049 c'est à dire avant le 100e
anniversaire de la prise de pouvoir en
1949 mais tout le monde a compris qu'en
réalité sachant qu'il est encore jeune
il voulait que ça arrive durant son
mandat
enfin un de ces mandats dit ce qu'il est
maintenant président à vie mais donc
c'est quand même renouveler
régulièrement et donc tout le monde a
compris que c'était dans les cours des
années 2020 que il souhaitait sous son
commandement que la chine devienne la
première puissance du monde et au moment
où il a annoncé ça ça a été comme une
décharge électrique chez les américains
qui ont commencé à se dire voilà il a dû
jeter le gant sur la table et donc on
relève le défi et on va se battre pour
rester la première puissance du monde
il faut bien comprendre que le conflit
entre la chine et les états unis pour la
première place mondiale
il va continuer après l'épisode de
coronavirus c'est le premier point et le
deuxième qui nous concerne ici en europe
c'est que ce conflit pour la domination
entre la chine les etats unis il est là
pour trente ans c'est à dire que les 30
prochaines années
au plan mondial au plan géopolitique et
économique mondiale toute l'actualité
mondiale va être dominée par les effets
du conflit entre la chine et les états
unis
en attendant le coronavirus plombent
l'économie mondiale
ou pas alors ça plombe significativement
pour le premier trimestre toute la
question c'est de savoir si l'épidémie
se transforme en pandémie
il y avait un premier rendez vous qui
était le 8 février
c'est un rendez vous qui avait été
donnée par les épidémiologistes vers le
20 janvier
si si on commençait à avoir une baisse
du nombre de cas après le 8
on était sauvé maintenant on le point
culminant a été posé vers la fin février
donc si à partir de la fin février et
commence ay ay avoir une décrue pas
évident nombre de personnes à ce moment
là on ça reste sous contrôle quand il ya
une marge d'incertitude assez
significative
personne n'en parle en occident
aujourd'hui mais c'est quand même un
vrai problème on est parent n'est pas
certain de ce qui se passe au vietnam au
laos et au cambodge et peut-être même la
zone asiatique voilà parce que ces pays
ont beaucoup des changes avec les
chinois
c'est pas très loin du hubei pouvoir au
japon notamment
voilà et et oui mais le japon a un
système de santé qui me permet de
prendre les choses en main mais si le
virus est entré au vietnam on sait que
cette entrée au nord du vietnam que les
viêt nam vietnamiens ont fait comme à
hawan ils ont inséré une des villes du
nord du vietnam pour essayer de
contrôler le confiner complète voilà de
faire en sorte que le virus ne se balade
pas mais on a des raisons de penser que
le cambodge a été touché il est
vraisemblable que le laos est touché et
donc la grande question c'est est-ce que
même si les chinois arrivent à contrôler
la chose si ça s'est répandue au sud de
la chine dans ces pays qui n'ont pas les
systèmes de santé et surtout qu'ils ne
disent pas la vérité
est ce que est ce qu'il ya des cas qui
là qu'il cache comme en décembre en
chine
on pourrait avoir un épisode qui
reviennent sur ce coronavirus avec des
dégâts beau des dégâts d'autant plus
fort que ces états ne sont pas aussi
fort politiquement et que la chine et
donc ne serait pas en mesure de
contrôler aussi bien parce que ni de
fabriquer des hôpitaux en radio parce
que il faut reconnaître qu'à partir du
moment où ci a repris le contrôle de la
faire les chinois mène une lutte
extrêmement déterminée contre le
coronavirus pour les raisons que j'ai
évoquées ci c'est une façon de se
maintenir au pouvoir s'ils perdent le
contrôle de cette affaire vous savez moi
je les écris d'ailleurs à partir du
moment où vous prenez le pouvoir à vie
le risque c'est que pour vous sortir il
n'ya plus que la balle dans la tête
il le sait oui et ça c'est pas un risque
c'est pas mineure s'il perdait le
contrôle sur le coronavirus on se
retrouve dans une poignée de secondes
et là on se retrouve en europe
[Musique]
retour sur le plateau de la grande
interview avec christian saint-etienne
professeur d'économie au cta mme
christian on a beaucoup parlé de la
chine beaucoup parlé de son incidence à
la fois son impact politique en interne
mais aussi économique l'europe la france
aujourd'hui on a du mal à comprendre ce
qui s'y passe notamment sur la france ya
un mystère pendant quelque part c'est
que les chiffres sont bons notamment
pendant ce premier trimestre personne
n'est content personne n'est content ça
grogne partout on est au bord parfois de
de la colère de la révolte
comment expliques ça la réalité et le
ressenti sont si différents je pense
qu'il ya deux phénomènes qui explique ce
que vous évoquez le premier c'est le
fait qu'il ya deux france
alors c'est un phénomène général hawk
normes mondiales met donc pour expliquer
le problème en france c'est qu'il ya une
économie de premier rang en gros tous
ceux qui sont dans des cd ou des cdd de
long terme
et puis il ya une deuxième france à la
fois sous l'angle de ceux qui sont
faiblement inséré dans l'économie du
d'exercer déclassé et d'autre part vous
savez on a toujours cette diagonale de
l'a22 la faiblesse de l'évolution
économique qui part de charleville
mézières est qui et qui arrivent
jusqu'en charente et donc des
territoires où on a perdu énormément
d'emplois
c'est à dire que la désindustrialisation
de la france très très fort depuis 20
ans qui s'est traduite par une baisse de
30 % de la part de la valeur ajoutée
manufacturière terrasse et s'est
traduite par des fermetures de milliers
d' usine particulièrement dans ces
territoires parce que les usines de
production ne sont pas place de la
concorde
donc elles sont dans des territoires où
justement on peut mettre des usines mais
quand vous les fermes et les populations
n'ont pas d'alternative
mais derrière il ya plus
d'administration pour les calanques
cette faille telle a été la base du
premier phénomène de gilet jaune qui est
et venait de ces personnes déclassés ou
qui avaient perdu leur travail et le
deuxième phénomène qu'il faut nommer
c'est que d'une certaine façon la
personnalité des manuels macron est
toujours aux mêmes politiques
personnelles voilà c'est à dire que sa
personnalité est devenu un irritant
notamment pour cette population des
classes et parce que il a il a une façon
chronique est une façon d'être qui est
insupportable à cette population
et de fait il y a dans dont une
quinzaine à une vingtaine de pourcent de
la population française une dizaine de
millions de personnes
une vraie haine de macron et ça c'est un
élément l'or qui fait que tout incident
se traduit par une crise épidermique de
colère nature alors j'ai commencé en
disant les chiffres sont bons il faut
quand même pas exagérer on a quand même
des défaillances structurelles qui sont
importantes parce que est-ce que est ce
que ces défaillances structurelles vous
paraissent irréductibles ou pas au jour
d'aujourd'hui ça crie ça a l'air
compliqué compte tenu justement de la
difficulté politique
alors il ya une amélioration qui est
certaine et qu'étant par jour du qui est
en partie dû alors une amélioration
certaine pour la première économie
c'est-à-dire en gros pour 80% de la
population
il ya 80% de la population qui est
inséré où la visibilité s'est améliorée
avait une bonne visibilité qui a des
bonnes retraites quand ils sont à la
retraite qui ont des perspectives de
croissance de leur pouvoir d'achat quand
ils travaillent
bon donc il ya 80% de la population qui
vit bien
simplement il ya deux phénomènes
structurels majeurs la
désindustrialisation un maquereau a pris
des mesures en arrivant qui qui explique
en partie le fait que la conjoncture est
plutôt meilleur que tant d'hommes
temporairement que dans le reste de
l'europe
malgré tout ça la politique fiscale qui
l'a mise en oeuvre a fait en sorte que
les entrepreneurs ou les gens qui ont
des patrimoines ont csn partir on
retrouvait du dilemme est donc se sont
mis à réinvestir en france
donc de ce point de vue on le critique
pour en fait notamment sa réforme de
l'iace f où sa réforme de la fiscalité
du capital
mais de mon point de vue ce sont les
deux raisons clés de ce léger
bioéconomie que vous évoquez en revanche
il a fait deux erreurs de mon point de
vue qui vont le hanter jusqu'au bout il
n'a pas vraiment agi sur la dépense
publique
il a dit en arrivant qu'il allait le
faire mais avec les gilet jaune il a
renoncé à tort et donc ils se retrouvent
avec un problème de finances publiques
majeures
c'est à dire un problème mais déficit
récurrent et le 2 et le deuxième donc ça
l'empêchent de baisser les impôts très
fortement par exemple les impôts sur la
production
on a annoncé un pacte de compétitivité
mais en fait il y aura pas de mesure
significative parce qu'il ne peut pas le
faire et l'autre problème absolument
majeur qu'il n'a pas pris en compte
c'est la désindustrialisation c'est à
dire qu'il fallait arriver alors qu'un
paquet là sur la sur la
réindustrialisation qu'il a pas de
christian saint-etienne vous savez bien
ce que vous répondre à un certain nombre
d'économistes sur le financement c'est
que les conditions de financement
aujourd'hui compte tenu des politiques
monétaires font qu' on peut très bien se
permettre ce déficit là il ne nous coûte
rien alors ils se trompent sur un point
clé c'est que le déficit c'est la queue
du chien
le problème c'est le chien c'est à dire
la dépense publique c'est à dire que la
dépense publique qui en 2020 sera de 55
% du pib va monter c'est ses 10 points
de plus que l'allemagne
ces huit points de plus que les autres
pays
l'ensemble de la zone euro or ça ça se
traduit par un excès d'impôts qui
notamment d'impôt de la production qui
empêche que le petit frémissement qu'on
a évoqué tout à l'heure liés à aux
réformes fiscales de macron que ce petit
frémissement se traduisent par une vraie
reprise de la production
oui donc on a on a un pays qui vit il
faut toujours le rappeler a depuis 2001
la croissance moyenne de la france c'est
1,1
1,2 or notre pays a besoin de deux
heures à 17 heures devant encore vous
dire que vous vous comparer à
l'allemagne alors là sur le taux de
croissance que l'allemagne est un taux
de croissance plus faibles a nommé
l'allemagne est en décroissance était
mais bien sûr avec autant d'éclat oui
alors qu'ali d'une mono industrie ou
fondés sur l'automobile qui doit
compléter on se réformer et enfin il
sera aussi les machines dossier est
compliqué alors il faut avec des
équipements collectifs qui sont beaucoup
plus dégradé que les nôtres où est alors
moi je ne rentre pas dans cette approche
des gens qui sous-estiment l'allemagne
l'allemagne lagarde un outil industriel
extrêmement puissant et l'allemagne est
en fait dans son insertion dans
l'économie mondiale dans la même
position que le japon serre sont deux
pays qui produisent pour les les pays
qui développent leur industrie quand
vous avez une récession aussi bien en
allemagne au japon ils sur réagissent à
la baisse d'aidés qu'il ya une reprise
ils sur réagissent à la hausse
donc l'allemagne n'est pas foutu en plus
en terme de d'immigration ils vont
chercher tous les travailleurs formés en
italie en espagne or donc l'allemagne
n'est pas vous l'onglet donc la clé ça
pourrait être
l'entente entre la france et l'allemagne
alors une entente qui est le jazz elle
sait que j'aime compliqué rires oui
c'est une entente qui est difficile
parce que peu de gens osent le dire mais
je le dis il ya un retour en allemagne
depuis une dizaine d'années d'un mépris
pour la france parce que les allemands
n'ont pas compris qu'un pays adultes se
laisse désindustrialisé comme nous
l'avons fait ils n'ont pas compris la
politique nous avons donc ne travaille
pas pour l'europe voilà en disant ça
alors donc ils n'ont pas compris sur la
désindustrialisation pourquoi on n'a pas
réagi et ils ne comprennent pas pourquoi
depuis 50 ans on est en déficit que la
conjoncture soit bonne ou mauvaise
donc pour les allemands ce sont des
marques d'un pays inférieur et et donc
il ya un retour de l'idéologie de la
supériorité l'allemagne qui est
dangereux à moyen terme
mais vous avez évoqué en lien avec ça à
notre problème quand la france était
forte
jusqu'en 2000 c'était le leader naturel
de l'europe la france est un des deux
pays universaliste au monde avec les
états
unis quand nous étions forts nous
menions une politique européenne
en europe les allemands qui ont repris
le manteau jeu suite à la
désindustrialisation à l'affaiblissement
le il mène une politique allemande en
europe et donc c'est le procès la raison
de l'affaiblissement politique de il ya
quand même aujourd'hui un accord en
europe pour adopter une position commune
face aux briques site
face à la politique que mène boris
johnson
est ce que l'europe a raison de durcir
sa position dans la négociation qui va
régler la sortie de la grande-bretagne
est la raison deux fois deux fois la
première fois c'est parce que sont les
anglais qui sont à l'origine de la
guerre fiscale et sociale à l'intérieur
de l'europe
on a oublié que derrière qu'on a peur
que l'angleterre se transforme dans
singapour sur cette voie là c'est sûr
talent donc c'est eux qui dans le traité
de maastricht avait fait en sorte que
toutes les décisions fiscales tu restes
à l'unanimité il savait très bien que ça
va bloquer tout donc il savait que ça
bloqué tôt mais que surtout ça
permettait de mener des guerres fiscal à
l'intérieur de l'europe
on n'est pas menacée sur le plan fiscal
par la chine et par l'irlande à 12 et
demi donc c'est ce que veulent accentuer
les onglets en faisant du singapour en
europe met le deuxième point c'est que
si les 27 ne durcissent pas vis-à-vis du
royaume-uni à ce moment-là il y à
d'autres pays à l'intérieur de l'union
européenne qui vont se dire ah mais s'il
n'y a pas de coups à sortir peut-être
c'est mieux de sortir et vous avez une
portion croissante du peuple des pays
bas qui souhaite envisager une sortie
s'il si les anglais réussissent la
sortie et que ça leur coûte rien il ya
d'autres pays qui sortirait ce que boris
johnson n'a pas tardé il tape fort
équipements collectifs mesures sociales
tout ça financés par de l'emprunt de la
dette donc de la dévaluation de sa
monnaie et parallèlement sa monnaie est
actuellement et parallèlement des
régulations
régulation fiscale peut-être des
régulations sociales alors vous pointer
là deux phénomènes le premier c'est
l'émergence de ce qu'on appelle le
conservatisme social donc cette idée que
les conservateurs peuvent mener des
politiques sociales pour répondre au
populisme
donc ça c'est ce que fait johnson il le
fait bien
avec détermination c'est un opérateur
politique qui n'a pas de limite pas de
frein des il ira très loin donc raison
de plus pour l'union européenne à 27 2
le de le contrôler au départ n'est pas
certain qu'ils vont réussir que l'union
à 27 va réussir face à johnson l'autre
problème
l'autre question que vous évoquez c'est
la relance des investissements parce
qu'en fait vous souvenez que le break
site
londres a voté contre le break site et
ce sont les territoires autour qui ont
voté pour
donc le conservatisme social consiste
pour les réanimer à arroser les
territoires qui ont voté pour la soul et
les projets de tgv
voilà le problème la contradiction
interne de la politique de johnson c'est
que en faisant une politique fiscale de
dérégulation il va aggraver la cassure
entre le londres qui réussit et les
régions anglaise qui sont en perdition
donc s'il fait d'un côté des dépenses
publiques au bénéfice de ces régions un
peu isolé mais que par ailleurs il
accroît la dérégulation
ce sont les mêmes régions qui vont
prendre la dérégulation en pleine face
et donc il
il crée les conditions de d'une
rébellion de ces régions qui sont eux
qui sont en déshérence
en un mot parce que on a pratiquement
plus de temps est-ce qu'il ya quand même
des éléments d'optimisme sur le réveil
possible de l'europe
quand on voit l'opération alstom on se
dit ben écoutez les français et les
européens
ils peuvent quand même se sont sortis
quand on entend thierry breton sur
l'intelligence artificielle qui est en
train de lancer une campagne pour
essayer de réveiller l'europe on se dit
il y a des possibilités
la seule raison actuel de mise
l'optimisme c'est la nouvelle commission
avec van der leyen et surtout breton en
fait breton c'est l'atout principal de
l'europe pour revenir dans la course
la question c'est quelle est l'étendue
possible de son action est ce qu'il aura
une marge de manoeuvre suffisante et
malgré tout les allemands le laisseront
faire est ce que les allemands le
laisseront faire et malgré tôt est ce
qu'à un moment donné les français et les
allemands vont se retrouver pour mettre
en oeuvre une politique de rebond
stratégique de l'europe ou pas la
question reste sur la table dans la
mesure où ça fait dix ans que les
allemands bloque toute l'initiative n'a
pas d'autre solution
moi je suis très inquiet sur ce retour
de l' excès de supériorité de
l'allemagne de ressentis comme comme un
peuple qui rebondit à chaque fois et qui
regardent les français qui ne qui
n'arrive pas à se remettre d'aplomb et
ça je pense que c'est un une faille
secrète qui empêche l'europe de rebondir
christian saint-etienne merci beaucoup
pour ce tour d'horizon grande interview
on retrouve en rediffusion bien sûr sur
la chaîne en replay sur les sites
internet sur les réseaux sociaux
je rappelle le site internet rtl france
point tv à bientôt
[Musique]